in the book you talk a very funny book
you talk about how often you get
mistaken for other celebrities well yeah
when's the last time that happened it
happens all the time happens all the
time
oh yeah it happens all the time I may
you know the airports are a great
equalizer that's what no matter who you
think you are that's where you find out
who people really think you are and I
still remember when I first got famous
in 1992 and I was walking through an
airport and people were kind of looking
at me and smiling and pointing and I was
like I am finally famous right and this
couple comes up to me and they go can we
take a picture and get your autograph on
it yeah so I take a picture with them
and I sign for the guy and I write all
the best Denis Leary and he goes what
the hell is this and I go it's all the
best Denis Leary he goes we thought you
were Willem Dafoe the autograph and the
trainee throws it away so that was the
beginning of me realizing that my entire
the entire time I've been famous I've
been humbled by the fact that I'm
mistaken constantly for Willem Dafoe
like when he did a spider-man he was the
Green Goblin
I was the Green Goblin it's you probably
got people congratulating you great good
job all the time so and now I just found
out recently I've been traveling a lot
and people at TSA are going to me hey
congratulation on your award for that
movie and I'm like oh so I google it
he's won all these acting awards for
this movie the Florida Project he's
probably going to get nominated for an
Oscar and probably win and so am I
[Applause]
I hope something is this right I'm sorry
go ahead no go ahead
you're also been mistaken for a female
celebrity well here you what the whole
list you've more than Y yeah yeah so
here's the list I get mistaken mostly
but the phone number one number two
Kevin Bacon
I get Footloose all the time yeah number
three Bryan Adams number four Jon Bon
Jovi number five Jane Lynch
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so bad for Jane Lynch whenever that
happens and it's because I was doing
this show sex and drugs and rock'n'roll
I was wearing when I like to call
gender-fluid jackets which is basically
a woman's jacket put on me right and and
and jewelry and stuff and this woman one
of the first things we were shooting I
was like I look pretty cool they look
like a rock star I'm supposed to be a
rock star and we've had this we're
shooting on a block in New York and it
was blocked off with police barricades
and this woman at the end of the shot
when they called cut she want I have to
go to work I just get a quick picture I
go yeah so she comes to the barrack and
I take the picture and as she's
finishing she's hailing a cab she goes
Glee's my favorite show and you're my
favorite character oh my god oh my god
but you know that's my that's my career
man I'm oh yeah by the way the people
I'm mistaken for people love people are
always that's how they see me because
they think I'm Jane Lynch or right Ellen
DeGeneres or a worse people right now
that think they're at the Ellen papers
100 yards that way
you